black conferences back from Vegas where
where everyone is hustling ever it's a
hustle all the way across the board I
think just the girls are hustling right
well no I think the guys I think
everybody's got an agenda feel it from
the guy just everybody it's everybody's
working it's like I feel like literally
I feel like everyone is lying about
everything
I feel like everyone's lying about
everything and it's fine
because you when you go therefore we had
a great meal we had a great time great
show by the way that was a fun real fun
show how about JJ Walker fantastic we'll
get to him he's a good he's a very good
sort of segue because JJ's been on the
road well since 1968 and he hit us with
that the first thing that Jed JJ
dynamite that on my Walker who's been
doing stand-up and been performing six
years since well yeah he's 72 years old
been doing since he's 20 so yeah so
you're talking about you know 40 years
50 years no I'm a long dynomite yeah and
so so dynamite was only four years ago
the first thing he said is he goes now
you guys are the comedy duo and we said
well we're separate acts but he said
mm-hmm now hmm I know everybody I know
everybody so when I saw your name I was
like yes exactly this head so Brennan I
was like we were like what is that a
good thing yikes yeah it's like Oh yikes
you and I go yikes when somebody's not
that good yeah he's so he goes hey I
know everybody too and I've seen it but
then and he said it again he goes but I
saw you guys and I was like yo this joke
I was like so what does that mean
you don't know us I guess and he goes
brain and Schwab y'all bring you up I
was in their job of job I go he'll
definitely say swab god
funny he did this thing hey man y'all
these reality shows man I'll tell you
what that [ __ ] Jersey Shore am i right
honey boo boo he did have dated remedies
but he had good energy I'll tell you I
can't wait
Jurassic Park to come out man I've been
waiting den dinosaur but me and me and J
actually laughs he was funny yeah he's
fun he's he's he's a great performer but
so humble
even dua your opening for your emcee in
this right okay cool so you know this is
good because he got he got Brendan's
name wrong so but before that JJ said I
got t-shirts and I got I got signed
autographs and I also pictures and I got
CDs CDs coming free so Brennan he is now
Brendon Schwab so Brendan goes to say
shakes hand I guess he was joking around
goes don't touch me
he goes don't touch me brother and it
burns like oh that was because I saw him
like pull it on stage you went to and he
goes no turd laughing yeah he goes don't
touch me and he walked away I was like
that's weird and then so um the
Brendan's first joke is whoa CDs huh
yeah I guess I'm in an episode of Hot
Tub Time Machine so phillium in hot tub
times make sure you get this
make sure you je t'ai CDs in the back
[ __ ] nice guy though but he's he's that
that 250 days in the road
for 450 years legend bro it's weathered
and so and I'm sure they'll say anything
about me when I'm 72 well they're saying
it now they are saying it now but do you
notice that in Vegas what you'll see is
like because I see all these people
hustling girls the girls it's all one
big house phone talking get your dick
sucked anyone you see if you fly in for
the weekend my work MA get your money
and leave money get money and leave
hottest girls in the planet now they
don't save their money typically
typically they don't save their money
and financial advisor I'm trying to bust
nuts girl that's it because they figure
that they I understand but they think
the trains gonna keep going but you know
how that ends you know how that story
ends and what I think is interesting is
in in Vegas you can see the people that
have never left the girls that came
there and somehow got stuck there but
now that desert air the smoke but their
skin looks like they got I've seen
better skin on a rhinoceros it's tough
man but also it's like it's so short
sight it's almost like professional
sports a little bit like bottle service
girls so I have some friends who work in
the bottle service industry they are
gorgeous and they make so much money but
then that's you know you're 30
7:38 you might have a house or something
like that but then once the oh I'm sorry
Dana
oh no there's new crop of girls coming
so dirty 738 see ya because your
lifestyle really haven't found a man you
don't have a ton of savings for you
getting all this cash so you're awesome
at lying to all the men so they don't
know buddy but not naive the line part
that's what ever some of them are
actually really good people so but a lot
of it you just don't it's it's so
one-sided got you get done you have
nothing to fall back on your looks are
making the money you're like dude I'm 38
and all I know how to do is grab giant
bottles of Courvoisier so to make it
[ __ ] rain on guy it's like it's such
a yeah
then the smart ones hustle get their
money and bounce when they're still in
their prime yes but even the beauty even
like the showman like even JJ the Vegas
active it's a it's a Vegas like you
Liberace Hamm David you know Copperfield
like hey yeah yeah yeah it's like this
funny sense of security and the girls
are all together so they're all kind of
having a good time at that point they're
they're at that age they get so much
attention they're making so much money
if you're not saving that and putting it
towards something so more so I've known
something yeah there's these beasties
they start their own businesses that's
my thing if you're gonna hustle no
problem I love you for us like just just
make sure you're building something that
you can fall back on when you're 38 and
the music stops because the music I love
the smart ones some ones I know buy a
property that you have like four
properties there you go that's what you
want to do yeah there's some smart ones
then I'll see there's get a nest egg
majority of dum-dums yeah get a nest egg
that JJ walk was funny that was fun
he was so he kept going like this he
kept showing me pictures he goes I write
with these guys they they worked with me
I don't know if you've seen this out if
you've heard of these guys like oh yeah
that's Jay Leno and because I don't of
yours I'm the funny part though
what kind of phone with it oh yeah it
was the muscle it's cool it was the
original iPhone you couldn't see I was
like is that black and white he's great
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
Oh [ __ ] business